قطط الشهداء بثلاجات
حجزوا عليها الخواتم
الشهداء الفلسطينيين في الثلاجات او في
مقابر سريه تسمى مقابر الارقام يمنع
الدخول اليها وتعتبر مناطق عسكريه مغلقه
الجثث تتطاير على الارض بشكل واضح مغطى
باكياس بلاستيكيه بدون علامات احتلال
الاسرائيلي عندما يقوم بدفن هذه الجثامين
يقوم بدافنها بدون تحديد هويه المدفون
داخل هذا القدر وقد يدفن اكثر من جثمان
بنفس القدر بدانا البحث عن ملفات وارشيف
يتعلق بمصير المفقودين الفلسطينيين ومن
ضمن الملفات التي استوقفتنا ملف انيست
دوله الذي استشهد داخل سجون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واختفى جثمانه منذ ذلك التاريخ
عام 1908
حتى هذه اللحظه الاحتلال يقول انه لا يملك
اي معلومه عن جثمان الشهيد انيس دوله
تباطؤ في الارسال الى المستشفى واقول لم
يرسل الى المستشار ممكن اخذه وضائه وممكن
انه باعه جثته للجامعه والا اين جثته
ابو كبير لاجراء مقابله مع طبيب او متحدث
مسؤول للبحث عن اجوبه حول ظروف الشهداء
هنا لكن دون جدوى
انا شو بعرفني انه ابني
تصوير في مقابر الارقام ولكن كل محاولاتنا
في التواصل عبر الايميل او عبر الهاتف لم
تنجح
دخلنا الى طريق الالتفافي يقودنا الى
المقبره وما ان قاربنا الى الوصول حتى
لحقتنا سياره تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي
ومنعتنا من التصوير تتبعنا هذا الملف
تزامنا مع خبر الافراج عن الشهيد يوسف ابو
جزر والذي كان محتجزا في ثلاجات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ ثلاث سنوات
في الاسعافات الاوليه وكيف بتعاملوا معي
انا بتعاملوش
[موسيقى]